monsieur le Président c'est un rappel au
règlement l'article 44 bis également
alors chers collègues ce qui se passe
depuis quelques jours de au sein de
cette émission qui est quand même
particulièrement gravissime si on
remonte un peu l'histoire vous avez
commencé tous ces procédés depuis les
manifestations massives de mardi depuis
que vous avez vu que les Françaises et
les Français étaient massivement
mobilisés vous avez commencé à pratiquer
ces manœuvres pour accélérer le texte
pourquoi puisque plus nous parlons du
texte plus nous parlons du fond plus ça
vous dérange parce que nous mettons en
exergue l'injustice de ce texte face à
vous à tel point que plus nous en
parlons plus des personnes chez vous se
rétractent et retire leur vote et vous
savez que si nous continuons à débattre
il y aura de plus en plus de personnes
qui se rendront compte justement au sein
de cette hémicycle que cette réforme est
injuste que cette forme est brutale
c'est justement par rapport à cet
article 9 qui est sans aucun doute aussi
avec l'article 7 que vous avez voté un
des plus injustes vous vous dites ah
mais si on débat du fond il y aura
encore des personnes qui vont se
rétracter comme celles qui se sont
rétractées à l'article 7 étant demain il
est particulièrement juste c'est sur la
pénibilité justement laisser les
Français avoir le droit à se débat
laisser aux Français qui ont les métiers
les plus pénibles de pouvoir justement
qu'on débatte de ces choses là ça ça
serait l'honneur du Parlement et
actuellement vous foulez le Parlement
vous l'écraser avec vos mesures
si Monsieur blé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mon intervention est un rappel
réglement sur la base non pas comme
l'essentiel de des intervenants
précédents sur la base d'article 44 bis
monsieur la base de l'article 46 bis que
dit-il dans son deuxième alinéa il dit
la chose suivante les amendements sont
mises au voie dans l'ordre ci-après les
amendements de suppression et ensuite
les autres amendements en commençant par
ceux qui s'écartent le plus du texte
proposé et dans l'ordre où il s'y oppose
s'y intercale ou s'y ajoute toutefois
lorsque le Sénat a adopté une priorité
ou une réserve dans les conditions
fixées à la Linéa 6 de l'article 44
l'ordre de mise au voie est modifié en
conséquence
lorsqu'ils viennent en concurrence et
sauf décision contraire de la Conférence
des présidents ou décisions du Sénat sur
proposition de la Commission saisie au
fond les amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune à l'exception écoutez
bien à l'exception des amendements de
suppression et de rédaction globale de
l'article et donc nous contestons
absolument monsieur le Président
formellement le fait que par la décision
que vous nous proposiez il puisse y
avoir une disparition des amendements de
suppression qui doivent être examinés en
premier lieu et avant tout autre
[Musique]